on the baltic sea island of rügen classy
car expert Christophe hours driving a
lovely old car with a lovely name the
Borg part isabella built in 1954 it was
the brainchild of engineer and
industrialist Carl fw bored wat
an out of my feeble Herc artistic Gustav
Bauer says today there are vehicles to
suit every niche from off-road sports
cars to four-door coupe face but in the
1950s it was a different story mid-range
sedans boasted plenty of room but
offered little driving pleasure so thank
goodness car maker Carl W Borg part from
Bremen had a heart for family man who
liked to put the pedal to the metal his
Isabella was both family friendly and
fun to drive the German sports sedan was
born at the start the Isabella
experienced some teething problems but
that was little wonder the entire
vehicle was developed in just 10 months
Borg vard was famous for his
authoritarian leadership style and he
alone chose the car's name
he's up at Christophe says that Carl
board vard named it Isabella on a whim
when his engineers showed him the first
prototype and asked him what to call the
car he waved his hand and said fiercely
what do I care Colin Isabella Christophe
says kudos mr. Bovard a good name for a
good card in the 1950s the Isabella was
a cut above the competition in Germany
in terms of both looks and technology at
7,000 Deutsche marks it costs more than
a VW Beetle but less than a Mercedes
Ponton but as far as performance was
concerned the Isabella left both models
eating its dust Christophe says it can
go from zero to 100 kilometers an hour
in 25 seconds and have a top speed of
135 kilometers an hour that might not
sound very impressive today but in the
50s that meant it could overtake more
than half the cars on German roads in
1955 karlberg Vardis went even farther
with the Isabella TS with a top speed of
150 kilometers an hour it's at the
european standard in its class it's
great suspension made it a real curve
hugger
Borg vard had already attracted
attention with the haunts of fifteen
hundreds monocoque ponton body back in
1949 its successor the Isabella was more
elegant with its opulent chrome trim it
resembled the American cars of the 1950s
but the Isabella's curves and refined
roofline also lent it a style all its
own
[Music]
with seed benches in the front and back
the Isabella conceit six adults
comfortably that was the secret to the
model success pairing sportiness with a
dash of luxury
[Music]
the reliable 4 cylinder engine with its
side mounted camshaft had already been
used to power the haunts of 1500 thanks
to its fabulous suspension the isabella
is nimble on curves only one thing puts
a spanner in the works the leg out
Christophe says the steering column
gearshift was absolutely
state-of-the-art in the 50s even Porsche
thought about putting the gearshift for
his 356 behind the steering wheel but
ferry Porsche said no thank goodness he
says as this construction really hinders
quick gear changes and sporty driving
but even this little flock can't spoiled
the great package that is the Isabella
over 200,000 Isabella's were sold
between 1952 and 1964 the model was Carl
Borg guards biggest success none of the
other vehicles he produced under the
Borg guard Goliath or Lloyd Brandt's for
his popular
he's a bailiff outside Christophe says
the Isabella was bought guards greatest
triumph it was germany's first sporty
mid-range sedan and the dream machine of
family cars he says the Isabella spawned
a whole new vehicle class making it a
true milestone and automotive history
still the car couldn't save the board
guard company plagued by financial
troubles political intrigues and bad
planning Germany's largest privately run
car maker was forced to declare
bankruptcy in 1961
you